Mitt Romney was asked the other day will
you vote for Trump if he's the 2024
Republican nominee this is an
interesting question because there are
many Republicans who are starting to say
things like I would rather a different
nominee I would prefer that we just
nominate someone different and that it
not be up to me to decide on Election
Day do I vote for Trump or not let's
just pick a different nominee Mitt
Romney is speaking with a Clarity that
many Republicans are not speaking with
now this is not a look at how great Mitt
Romney is story this is a look at how
low the bar is story Mitt Romney is
clearly saying I would not support Trump
even if he were the nominee in 2024.
it's going to be hard to to knock him
off as our nominee if he became a
nominee I think he loses again and um
would you support him if he's the
nominee absolutely not uh and I mean I
get asked that I mean
look I I voted to remove him from Office
twice so uh I knew what your answer is
but the answer is and it's not just
because he he loses I mean that's that's
my reason that I offer to other people
who are big fans of his but but it's
also he's he's simply not a person who
ought to have the reins of the
government of the United States okay
very very clear Romney says it's not
just about I'd rather a different
nominee if he's the nominee I'm not
voting for him compare and contrast this
with some of the more spineless people
in the Republican Party William Barr
William Bart one of Trump's former
attorney generals Attorneys General said
uh this guy was a threat to democracy
all these horrible horrible things but I
don't know I mean if it's a Democrat I
might still have to vote for him
listen to this well I certainly have
made it clear I don't think he should be
our nominee and I'm going to you know
support somebody else for the nomination
but if he is the nominee and you have
your choices
Donald Trump or whoever's running on the
Democratic side would you vote for him
uh because I believe that the the
greatest threat to the country is the
progressive agenda being pushed by the
Democratic party it's inconceivable to
me that I wouldn't vote for the
Republican nominee wow wow threat to
democracy dangerous no business has no
clue what's going on but I mean that
Savannah please a Democrat I'm not going
to vote for a Democrat that would be
even worse and then Mitch McConnell even
who Trump has called his wife
I don't remember if Trump called his
wife ugly but he certainly called her
different names has attacked him as a
rhino just up and down slamming
McConnell even McConnell what was it 10
days ago when he was asked he played koi
with it and didn't rule it out in light
of what you said that there's no room in
your party for anyone Harbors these
anti-semitic views if Donald Trump wins
the Republican nomination would you
support him
look let me just say again
there is simply no room
in the Republican party for
anti-Semitism or white supremacy and
that would apply to all of the leaders
in the party who will be seeking
officers there you go so even Mitch
McConnell not ruling it out the bar is
very low
and Mitt Romney has exceeded that bar
make sure that you are subscribed to the
David Pacman Show YouTube channel it is
free unlike with voting and elections if
you have five Google accounts you can
subscribe five times to the YouTube
channel and I encourage you to do it
let's get to to 2 million we'll take a
quick break and be right back
our sponsor magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal that tastes amazing but without
the sugar carbs and the crazy
ingredients magic spoon has taken your
favorite childhood cereals and
brilliantly transformed them into
something you can feel good about eating
because each serving has zero grams of
sugar under five net carbs and is packed
with 13 grams of protein so it'll work
for keto and low carb but it's really
perfect for anyone who wants the
occasional sweet crunchy treat without
the sugar their portfolio of eight plus
unique delicious flavors allow you to
never get bored my favorite is maple
waffle but they've got the classics like
cocoa fruity frosted also cinnamon roll
blueberry muffin our entire team has
been eating magic spoon for years we
love it but if you don't they send you
all your money back it's really easy
magic spoon has been supporting the
David packman show for a long time they
all always give my audience five dollars
off when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below